oui
alors
faut-il qu'on soit expert d'un secteur
pour avoir un avis sur ce secteur et ce
qu'il faut qu'on ait des compétences et
des connaissances poussées pour pouvoir
prétendre faire évoluer un domaine quel
qu'il soit
c'est des questions je me suis posé très
très régulièrement
très régulièrement et moi je suis comme
vous je ne crois que ce que je vois et
je les ai vus les constater de mes yeux
et ce notamment grâce au projet thierry
projet chéri c'est celui que vous voyez
derrière moi c'est un projet de
robotique et notre objectif s'est
développé un compagnon robotique pour
les enfants en situation de spitz
alisation on travaille à cet objectif
avec une association qui s'appelle
primat et qui elle même porte le projet
et cette association prima intervient
depuis 11 ans déjà à minimiser justement
le les difficultés sociales que peuvent
rencontrer les enfants lors d'une
hospitalisation qu'elle soit récurrente
ou prolongée bon alors par contre je
vous avoue quelque chose ce soir je ne
connaissais rien à l'époque où j'ai
participé à créer cette idée et la
convertir en projet je ne connaissais
strictement rien ni à la mission de
primes à nos missions santé encore moins
la robotique qu'on s'accorde je suis
comme vous je connaissais ce que j'en ai
vu
est ce que j'en ai lu et c'est vrai qu'à
énormément de films sur le sujet donc on
a tous quand même une petite
connaissance de ce que ça veut dire la
robotique mais enfin l'essentiel de mes
compétences on pouvait le résumé très
simplement c'est à dire que j'avais
acquis l'ensemble de mes compétences et
connaissances en regardant le film wali
le petit dessin animé là oui c'est un
peu dur au départ pour créer un projet
bon pourtant aujourd'hui c'est un vrai
projet et on travaille dessus
quotidiennement et moi c'est un sujet
qui me passionne en plus donc ce que
j'aimerais bien voir avec vous ce soir
ce sont les méthodes et ce concours est
ensemble créer une espèce de recettes de
cuisine finalement pour comprendre
comment sans rien savoir sur un domaine
on peut arriver à intervenir dessus et a
passé du temps
finalement sur ce domaine sachant que
pour moi on parle d'un domaine qui selon
mon modeste point de vue est un domaine
qui crée du sens on peut résumer ça à
comment créer du sens alors il vient
d'où ce sens que j'évoque pour moi en
tout cas c'est mon avis sur sur le sujet
le sens de ce projet ces idées sociales
il est évidemment technologique parce
que moi je centralement tu fais un peu
comme vous je suis ingénieur et j'aime
la techno
ça me fait vibrer je sais pas pourquoi
mais voit un petit côté geek chez moi
mais ce que j'aimerais voir donc c'est
cette recette de cuisine alors pour ce
faire ce que je vous propose c'est de
vous raconter le début de ce projet la
création et puis ensuite ce qui m'a
permis de le convertir c'est à dire
vraiment de passer 10 d un projet pour
ce faire on va peut-être commencer par
le commencement
la création d'idées un projet c'est une
idée au départ
alors je sais qu'il est assez porteur de
vous présenter l'idée comme étant
quelque chose de très romanesque à la
création d'idées il faut forcément être
être dans quelque chose de transcendant
une espèce d'ascension d'une montagne
et puis on sait dépasser puis on a vu la
lumière est au bout et ben c'est est
chéri non pas du tout pas du tout alors
pour moi c'est beaucoup moins romanesque
j'attendais le tramway bordelais pardon
mais j'étais pas seuls dans la tente de
ce tramway j'étais avec deux partenaires
d'innovation avec lesquels je venais de
finir justement un précédent projet et
on se demandait mais si on avait carte
blanche sur quoi est ce qu'on pourrait
sur quoi ce qu'on souhaiterait
finalement travaillées alors à ce stade
on s'est envoyé plein de mots clés des
mots-clés bon pour moi c'était robotics
et aide à l'enfance etc
mais c'était que des mots clés par
contre ces mots clés nous ont fait
penser à la mission de prima puisqu'on
connaissait prime à part sa mission et
on a su qu'il fallait qu'on aille à la
rencontre de florence gotek et la
présidente de l'asso et qui en fait nous
a expliqué sa mission est ce qu'ils
avaient fait jusque là il avait
développé déjà pour ses enfants un petit
logiciel web donc une application il
avait permis la diffusion d'ordinateurs
dans les jambes pédiatrique pour que les
enfants puissent aller sur internet
consommer des services
tu avais fait développer prime à
consommer des contenus qu'ils avaient
sécurisé prima au travers de leurs
applications
dans l'idée que ça puisse leur permettre
de s'abstraire du quotidien un peu
morose quand même d'une chambre
d'hôpital
bon donc a priori de phuket effet
finalement et plus grand chose à faire
en fait si parce que ce que ce conte ce
que constater par dont l'association
c'est que ce logiciel n'était pas autant
utiliser qu'elle l'aurait souhaité les
enfants n'allaient pas spontanément se
connecter comme je vous le disais
l'hospitalisation c'est pas forcément
très simple et donc il n'avait pas envie
de donc il fallait toujours les prendre
par la main et les accompagner or ce qui
fait cruellement défaut dans le monde de
l'hôpital
c'est évidemment la main d'oeuvre on va
dire donc la question se pose est est ce
qu'on aurait une techno qui nous
permettrait d'inciter les enfants à
aller consommer du contenu des services
numériques
et là évidemment j'avais vu wali donc je
sais que la robotique et humanoïdes
notamment un de ces enjeux c'est bien de
jouer sur les nouvelles interactions
pour permettre ce type de de service
justement
bah là on s'est dit on vient de définir
les contours de l'idée du projet de
série on était à peu près en phase là
dessus c'est que ces quelques
partenaires et moi même on s'était dit
ok c'est bien ça qu'on veut faire donc
là vous avez votre idée vous êtes
content c'est génial en soi l'idée folle
à convertir il faut faire passer ça en
mode projet justement pour pouvoir
intervenir dessus réaliser vraiment
quelque chose donc dans un premier temps
ce que vous faites ce que vous voulez
démontrer que votre vision que cette
idée elle est pertinente
bon sauf que comme je vous disais moi je
connais strictement rien la robotique
j'apprécie beaucoup mes partenaires de
l'époque ce que j'ai cités à l'instant
mais il connaissait pas grand chose non
plus donc on allait chercher des
compétences et des connaissances à
l'extérieur vous voyez ça fait un
certain nombre un nombre certain de
partenaires parce que c'est un projet
très transverses
on a besoin de beaucoup de monde mais à
chaque question qu'on voulait qu'on se
pose et finalement quand il fallait
convertir cette idée quand vous les la
concrétiser eh ben on a vu une réponse
qui nous était donnée par un père craint
partenaires expérimentés du secteur
donc a priori on était bon et plus qu'à
fallait réaliser ce démonstrateur
sauf que pour réaliser un démonstrateur
ça veut dire rentrer dans le dur ça veut
dire on y va et il faut des réalisateurs
et puis en plus il n'y a pas forcément
de but d' objectif tout à fait défini il
n'y a pas voilà c'est compliqué faut
dynamiser ce dispositif
donc on a fait le choix d'ouvrir le
dispositif en fait de l'intégrer à une
compétition qui s'appelle le défi h nous
défier âge c'est une compétition qui est
créé donc par sogeti france et le monde
informatique et qui vise en fait à faire
concourir des équipes d'étudiants sur
des projets innovants qui visent à
résoudre des problématiques de handicap
donc dans notre cas le handicap social
que peuvent rencontrer les enfants
justement à l'hôpital l'avantagé d'une
compétition c'est ce que je veux dire
c'est dynamiser le dispositif mais il ya
un autre avantage qui est intéressant
dans le cadre de notre projet c'est que
c'est un projet qui a un impact sociétal
c'est à dire qu'au travers de ce projet
là on est en train d'utiliser la
robotique dans un contexte de société et
au travers de toutes les fictions que
vous avez vu vous savez comme moi que
c'est un vrai sujet pas mal ça la fait
se poser beaucoup de questions
donc on a éclaté le dispositif on l'a
ouvert au travers de cette compétition
pour eux également permettre à tout le
monde de s'intéresser à ce qu'on faisait
donc c'est bon il y avait tout on a
trouvé quatre étudiants fait qu'ils
étaient particulièrement intéressés par
l'idée et on leur a proposé donc de
concourir de s'inscrire sur sur notre
thématique pour nous montrer ce qu'ils
savaient faire et comment concrétiser
cette idée mais maxime et attends tu as
une idée temps est convaincue qu'elle
est bonne
tu dis qu'il faut montrer la pertinence
à l'extérieur et tu mets ça entre les 24
étudiants ça c'est risquer quoi ils ont
joué le jeune il n'a pas de compétence
sait rien faire le jeûne non c'est pas
grave alors déjà je peux pas vous dire
ça parce que moi même j'en fais partie
donc ce serait un petit peu bizarre
par ailleurs je suis convaincu que dans
ces sujets là ces sujets techniques et
techno c'est très intéressant de bosser
avec des jeunes en l'occurrence des
étudiants pourquoi tout simplement parce
que vous comme moi on a baigné dans la
technique et la techno on est très
rapidement amenée à se concentrer sur
l'usagé qu'on va faire de cette
technique et cette techno on monte
rapidement en compétences sur ces
problématiques techniques et techno je
pense que vous avez compris l'idée
c'est plus agréable de pouvoir se
concentrer avec eux sur l'objectif de
notre démonstration plutôt que les
problématiques techniques
bon ça ses premiers points le second
c'est qu'on intervient sur un domaine
qui est compliqué si aujourd'hui on
voulait vraiment réaliser et c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire justement
donc je vous garantis vu le c'est en
voulant réellement réalisé ce des
monstres se produit maintenant on se
rend compte qu'il ya des normes très
très compliqué auquel il faut faire
attention à l'époque quand vous voulez
démontrer s'en fiche des normes vider
cette sortie recettes convaincre et les
étudiants ils connaissent pas les normes
donc ils s'embarrasse pas
particulièrement de connaître justement
ces problématiques et ne se crée pas de
barrière à la créativité
donc c'est top on avait cinq mois de
compétition des jeunes motivés créatif
et puis à priori comme je vous disais
concentré sur un objectif de plus value
voilà très bien et on a bien fait de le
faire
on a bien fait de le faire parce que
grâce à ces quatre jeunes on a pu
remporter deux prix lors de cette
compétition
le premier c'est un fait de
communication et le second c'est un prix
qui est vraiment nous a motivés on va
dire pour continuer pour aller plus loin
c'est le prix du public comme il
l'appelle alors dans le cadre du défi
agent fait ya des votes en ligne qui
sont organisés et sur l'ensemble des
votes en ligne qui avait été organisée
le projet de série a eu 35 % des votes
sur 9 équipes en compétition pas mal et
en fait dans le cadre d'un projet qui
impacte les sociétés c'est même très
bien parce que nous on l'a vécu comme
étant un indicateur que l'idée était
même séduisante pour nos citoyens nos
concitoyens quel qu'il soit et donc ça
c'est important et intéressant
ça nous a permis de d'aller plus loin
alors on a continué donc comme je vous
le disais à dynamiser ce dispositif est
aujourd'hui on a trouvé un nouveau
partenaire qui comme nous est intéressé
par ces deux thématiques par ces
dynamiques d'innovation ouverte on va
dire et on a renforcé la façon qu'on
avait travaillé en mode open
en prenant place dans un fab lab le fab
lab espace ouvert où n'importe qui en
gros on peut rentrer et sortir
l'idée étant d'agréger des compétences
diverses et variées sur un sujet en
l'occurrence pour nous c'est thierry
donc vraiment on a fait naître ce projet
dans le cadre de la compétition et on a
continué à le faire vivre
par la suite alors aujourd'hui on en est
un petit peu plus loin que ça mais là je
vous ai raconté la création donc ce qui
nous a permis de créer l'idée l'a trouvé
puis ensuite la convertir comme je le
disais je vous avais promis qu'on
essaierait de trouver la recette de
cuisine qui vous permette comme me
permettre de créer un autre projet sur
n'importe quelle thématique sous réserve
que vous soyez intéressé par cette
thématique
bon j'aurais peut-être dû vous faire une
petite confession je connais rien à la
cuisine une recette c'est pas mon truc
et puis je crois pas qu'on puisse
vraiment trouvé de recettes
par contre je vais vous donner quelques
ingrédients quand même parce que grâce à
ce projet je suis convaincu que si je
les réutilise dans mon prochain dans ma
prochaine création de projets et
conversion ça m'aidera forcément ces
ingrédients c'est la motivation la
motivation et les convictions
saint-exupéry dans sa citation que vous
affichez nous dit qu'il faut garder le
cap et souvent alors mois déjà la
citation à l'époque quand je commençais
à travailler tu as trouvé super jeu mais
où est le cap fonctionnel le cap du
produit quoi ce conte ce qu'on veut
faire
non non c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui je ne
vois pas comme ça c'est pas le cap
produit c'est le cap des convictions
c'est ce vers quoi vous voulez
travailler qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire changer finalement parce que dans
cette
dans ce temps de cinq mois votre produit
il évolue tellement vite ça sert à rien
de faire des plans des plans sur la
comète
par contre il faut que vous accordiez
tous sur ce que vous voulez faire
changer et en gardant ce cap
vous créez une motivation qui permet de
lier les partenaires que vous avez vu
nombreux mais également de réaliser on
va dire et concrétiser cette idée
donc ça c'est le premier point sur
lequel je ne renierai pas lors de ma
prochaine création d'idées
le second point c'est que quand on crée
des idées on a tendance à vouloir
rationaliser tout process on se dit mais
attendez une idée un moment donné faut
pas juger la pertinence
il faut qu'on dise un plus un égale deux
ont posé des indicateurs on prend des
décisions on arbitre il faut tendre à
rationaliser ça je suis d'accord c'est
un peu après avoir une approche
raisonnée c'est normal un moment donné
faut la voir
mais gardez vous le temps aussi d'avoir
une approche passionnés c'est à dire une
idée et notamment dans ces étapes là les
premières ça tient notamment grâce à vos
convictions à vos passions et c'est elle
qui vous permettent de passer d'étape en
étape c'est petit et abstrait de suite
très successives avant en effet
d'arriver vers de vrais indicateurs et
sapho par rené dessus en tout cas moi je
fais le pari à partir de depuis thierry
finalement qu' il faut travailler
d'autant ses convictions pour bosser
dans la passion et la passion en plus
comme nous le dit confucius ça permet de
pas vraiment avoir le sentiment du
travail
c'est ça qui est intéressant si vous
êtes dans l'exercice de quelque chose en
l'occurrence l'exercice du coût de vos
convictions et ça c'est très intéressant
qu'on voulait créer des sites et donc
moins en faisant ce pari j'espère que ça
me permettra justement devenir
reproposer de nouvelles idées très
incessamment merci à tous